es ist ja gerade einiges los in der
deutschen Sicherheitspolitik drei Dinge
die vor zwei Wochen noch anders waren er
hier ist neu im Amt wir liefern jetzt
Leopard 2 Panzer an die Ukraine und der
Kanzler erklärt sich und spricht Olaf
Scholz hat vor allem um eins gebeten
vertrauen Sie mir und tut ihr das geht
euch das alles gerade zu schnell oder zu
langsam was ist aus den Bedenken
geworden der eskalationsgefahr kämpfen
wir nun gegen Russland wie die
Außenministerin hier in diesem Video
sagt dass in den sozialen Netzwerken
kursiert we are fighting against Russia
and not against each other thank you
ich denke wir haben alle gerade viele
Fragen hier ein inside-politics zur
panzerentscheidung
[Applaus]
mein Name ist Andrea Maurer ich bin
hauptstadtkorrespondentin und
beschäftige mich mit Sicherheitspolitik
also jetzt erstmal zum Kanzler was
treibt ihn an und vor allem warum hat er
so entschieden wie er entschieden hat
klar ist Scholz hat zwei Prinzipien
niemals alleine Schritt für Schritt für
Schritt das ist das Hauptprinzip für das
sich Scholz im Umgang mit dem russischen
Präsidenten entschieden hat die
Amerikaner nennen das auch cooking the
frog ihr kennt das oder ein Frosch sitzt
in einem Wassertopf die Temperatur wird
langsam hochgedreht er merkt nicht dass
das Wasser im heißer wird bis es am Ende
zu spät ist und er nicht mehr rauszupfen
kann Putin das ist der Frosch was Scholz
offenbar erreichen will Putin soll
irgendwann einfach aufhören verhandeln
oder abgesetzt werden aber bitte vorher
nicht durchdrehen jetzt zum Prinzip
niemals alleine heißt eigentlich nicht
ohne die Amerikaner warum ihm das so
wichtig ist erstens Deutschland ist
keine Atom macht und braucht den
atomaren Schutzschirm der USA zweitens
Militärhilfe für die Ukraine lässt sich
über längere Zeit nur mit der größten
nato-militärmach durchhalten für die
europäischen Nato-Partner allerdings ist
das auch ein Affront und das wiederum
bietet dem Oppositionsführer vier Grund
für Kritik das Olaf Scholz
offensichtlich allein den amerikanischen
Staatspräsidenten für denjenigen hält
die auf seine Augenhöhe spielt und der
mit ihm zusammen dann Entscheidungen
trifft in Europa hinterlässt das viel
Verstimmung wie seht ihr das war es das
wert immerhin haben wir jetzt eine große
panzer-allianz und die Amerikaner sind
dabei hat euch Scholz da überrascht und
überhaupt wie tickt eigentlich der Mann
im Kanzleramt der erst wochenlang
schweigt und dann liefert
[Musik]
am Tag als er die Entscheidung verkündet
hat da jedenfalls hat sich der Kanzler
kurz in den Kopf schauen lassen er hat
sich im Parlament erklärt und später
hier im ZDF bei was nun Herr Scholz ihr
habt da öffentlich einen Olaf Scholz
gesehen den wir Hauptstadt schonnalisten
bisher so eher im Hintergrund Gespräch
erleben hier ein paar Ausschnitte klar
ist die Presseerklärung die man zuletzt
gemacht hat und die nächste
Presseerklärung ist nicht der Maßstab
für internationale Politik die Agenda in
anderen Hauptstädten richtet sich auch
nicht daran wann jemand mal wieder im
Fernsehen auftreten will der Kalender
solche Entscheidungen in anderen
Hauptstädten richtet sich nicht nach
irgendwelchen Ereignissen die hier in
Deutschland oder anders wo stattfinden
ich übersetze das mal erstens die
Debatte die auch in den Medien geführt
wurde nervt den Kanzler sichtlich aber
er tut sie als unwichtig ab für Scholz
sind Leute wie Maria Zimmermann oder
Anton Hofreiter fast schon
kriegstreiberische Gegenspieler die erst
durch die Medien groß gemacht werden
zweitens ein Treffen die internationale
Geberkonferenz in Ramstein oder das
Treffen mit macron in Paris auf die die
Augen der Welt gerichtet sind sind für
ihn tatsächlich kein Grund
Entscheidungen zu treffen dafür dass
Olaf Scholz niemals alleine zu seinem
Prinzip erklärt hat sieht er sich doch
als ziemlichen Solitär der alleine nach
seinem eigenen Takt handelt mitgenommen
hat er Bevölkerung unverbündete auf dem
Weg der Entscheidungsfindung jedenfalls
kaum und jetzt wo die panzerwände da ist
was hat sich geändert und welche Rolle
spielt Deutschland nun in diesem Krieg
[Musik]
die Außenministerin hat in dieser Woche
im Europarat ein ziemlich
aufsehenerregenden Satz gesagt we are
fighting against Russia and not against
each other thank you
Werbung habe damit klar machen wollen
dass Europa gegen diesen Krieg
zusammenhalten muss heißt es später das
Auswärtige Amt verschickt dazu auf
Anfrage diese Klarstellung Achtung sehr
kompliziert formuliert das Völkerrecht
ist eindeutig die Ukraine dabei zu
unterstützen ihr in der un-kater
verbrieft ist individuelles
Selbstverteidigungsrecht gegen den
völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieg
Russlands auszuüben macht Deutschland
nicht zu einer Konfliktpartei
völkerrechtlich lautet die Antwort also
nein Deutschland ist nicht im Krieg mit
Russland das hat auch Olaf Scholz bei
was nun nach der leopard-entscheidung so
gesagt ist Deutschland damit
Kriegspartei nein in keinem Fall und
darum ging es auch zu keiner Zeit
trotzdem wird immer wieder auf dieses
Gutachten des wissenschaftlichen
Dienstes vom vergangenen früher
verwiesen unter der ZDF-Sendung was nun
beispielsweise haben Zuschauer viele
Kommentare gepostet die sich darauf
beziehen ich lese mal einen vor da
schreibt Michael herr Scholz kann sich
jetzt auch nicht anders Gutachten des
wissenschaftlichen Dienstes des
Bundestages erinnern herr Scholz mit der
Lieferung der Panzer und der Ausbildung
der Besatzung sind wir Kriegspartei
ähnlich hat sich diese Woche auch die
Linke Fraktionsvorsitzende Amira
Mohammed Ali geäußert bereits im letzten
Jahr im letzten Jahr im Mai hat ein
Gutachten des wissenschaftlichen
Dienstes des Bundestages aufgezeigt dass
Deutschland dadurch völkerrechtlich als
Kriegsteilnehmer gewertet werden könnte
und was das für Konsequenzen hätte ich
glaube das muss ich nicht eher näher
ausführen also die Lieferung von Waffen
in Kombination mit der Ausbildung
ukrainische Soldaten in Deutschland
könnte als Kriegsbeteiligung gewertet
werden fakt ist in diesem Gutachten
steht wenn neben der Belieferung mit
Waffen auch die Einweisung der
Konfliktpartei bzw Ausbildung an solchen
Waffen in redestunde würde man den
gesicherten Bereich der nicht
Kriegsführung verlassen da steht aber
eben nicht dass man automatisch so
Kriegspartei wird sondern nur unter
Umständen werden kann ich habe mal meine
Kollegin die Leiterin unserer
rechtsredaktion von sarattacke um eine
Einschätzung gebeten es stimmt durch die
Ausbildung ukrainischer Soldaten an
Waffen die wir liefern geht Deutschland
einen entscheidenden Schritt weiter aber
Deutschland wird dadurch nicht
automatisch Kriegspartei wenn
Deutschland Waffen liefert und
ukrainische Soldaten daran ausbildet
sind wir in der Grauzone Deutschland ist
aber dadurch immer noch nicht
automatisch Kriegspartei erst wenn
Deutschland sich direkt in militärischer
Operationen einwischt erst dann ist
Deutschland ganz klar Kriegspartei genau
da verläuft die brisante rote Linie dass
das Völkerrecht den russischen
Präsidenten wenig kümmert wissen wir
spätestens seit der völkerrechtswidrigen
Annexion der Krim im Kreml wertet man
die Leopard panzerentscheidung übrigens
nun als direkte Mitwirkung der
westlichen Allianz an dem Krieg dazu
sagt Dimitri pescop der Sprecher des
russischen Präsidenten alles was die
Allianz und die Hauptstadt Europas und
der USA tun wird in Moskau als direkte
Beteiligung am Konflikt aufgefasst das
ist natürlich auch massives Säbelrasseln
der Russen soll die Bevölkerung
hierzulande verunsichern Angst machen
und den kanzlerkurs Schwächen aber
völlig klar ist es gibt diese Ängste und
viele fragen sich was kommt jetzt als
nächstes
[Musik]
mit der kanzlererklärung Schritt für
Schritt stellt sich natürlich auch die
Frage aber wohin zur Erinnerung diese
Regierung hat mit ihrer Unterstützung
für die Ukraine mal bei 5000 Helmen
angefangen kaum ist die
leopard-entscheidung gefallen wünscht
sich der ehemalige ukrainische
Botschafter in Deutschland und jetzige
stellvertretende Außenminister Melnik
F16 F35 Eurofighter Tornados und so
weiter und auch der ukrainische
Präsident selenski hat um Kampfflugzeuge
gebeten die Frage ist also jetzt ob
schon bald in der deutschen Debatte geht
nach den Leos ist vor den Tornados der
Kanzler war dazu im Parlament ziemlich
klar keine Kampfflugzeuge das ist nicht
um Kampfflugzeuge geht habe ich ja sehr
früh klargestellt und macht das auch
hier als diskutiert wurde über
Flugverbotszonen über der Ukraine habe
ich übrigens auch der amerikanische
Präsident gesagt das werden wir nicht
tun und an dieser Haltung hat sich gar
nichts geändert und wird sich auch
nichts ändern
und
Bodentruppen werden wir in keinem Fall
schicken ich habe gesagt es wird keine
direkte Beteiligung von Nato-Soldaten in
dem Ukraine Krieg geben ich habe dazu
auch noch mal die Vorsitzende des
Verteidigungsausschusses Marie
agnesstrack Zimmermann gefragt von der
der SPD-Fraktionschef Mütze nicht ja
vermutet hat dass sie am lautesten nach
Zitat Flugzeugen oder Truppen schreien
wird geschrien hat Maria hat eine stark
Zimmermann nicht sie klang für ihre
Verhältnisse sogar ziemlich leise was
wir auch unbedingt brauchen ist eine
Strategie nämlich was könnte passieren
im März im April wenn das Wetter sich
ändert wenn es wieder wärmer wird wenn
der Boden nicht mehr gefroren sondern
schlammig ist das heißt im militärischen
brauchen Sie ein Szenario und dann
müssen Sie die Lage anpassen das ist
viel wichtiger als jetzt nach dem Motto
jetzt kommt der Leopard Diskussion
beendet Haken dran jetzt machen wir ein
nächstes fast auf also nein keiner
Kampfflugzeuge trotzdem so meine
Prognose werden wir auch darüber noch
heftiger diskutieren völkerrechtlich
gilt auch bei Kampfflugzeugen was meine
rechts Kollegin Sarah immer gesagt hat
solange unsere Soldaten oder im Hinblick
auf den Bündnisfall Nato-Soldaten nicht
beteiligt sind sind wir keine
Kriegspartei allerdings liegt genau hier
ein Knackpunkt wie kämen die
Kampfflugzeuge in die Ukraine ich habe
noch mal in das Gutachten des
wissenschaftlichen Dienstes geschaut
würden sie von Nato-Soldaten geflogen
wäre das eine klare Eskalation würden
sie von ukrainischen Soldaten auf einem
nato-flughafen abgeholt während sie tat
die Grenzen zwischen Transport und
Eingriff in den Krieg deutlich poröser
so jedenfalls steht es im Gutachten
rechtliche Grauzone also entscheidend
bei all dem aber ist ohnehin was Putin
dem Völkerrecht ziemlich egal ist daraus
macht ob der Frosch also raus hüpft aus
dem Topf so und jetzt freue ich mich auf
eure Kommentare und Meinung laut unserem
aktuellen Politbarometer finden es 54%
richtig dass Deutschland Kampfpanzer vom
Typ Leopard 2 liefern will gehört ihr
dazu und wie sieht ihr das machen wir
jetzt bei den Leos Schluss oder müssen
wir mehr tun um der Ukraine zu helfen
sich gegen die anstehende russische
Frühjahrsoffensive zu verteidigen kann
die panzerallianz Putin stoppen
diskutiert gerne mit und abonniert doch
auch unseren Kanal hier findet Ihr immer
aktuelle Analysen und Hintergründe